so the NFL season kicked off last night
with an absolute nail-biter
of a game extremely exciting start to
finish final score 10 to 3 it was it was
as exciting as watching soccer a game it
was it was so that's about the level it
was at Packers won the game but the real
the real NFL related drama yesterday RIT
was was happening off the field and it
had to do with Saints quarterback Drew
Brees now drew Brees if you don't follow
the NFL Drew Brees is not only one of
the best quarterbacks in a league one of
the best quarterbacks in the history of
the league really but he's also just one
of the best all-around dudes in the
league he's just a he's a good decent
guy and they're you know despite what
maybe some people would say or the
impression somebody some people have of
the league there are a lot of good
decent men in professional football
there are also a lot of unhinged
narcissists and violent abusers in the
league too unfortunately if you follow
the league than you know about Antonio
Brown over and now he's in Oakland he
was in he was in Pittsburgh before and
he's definitely in the unhinged
narcissist camp the guy cares about
nothing but himself he causes problems
everywhere he goes everything's about
him Brees is not like that he's a good
team player he's a good guy in general
and and you know III think that people
who are star athletes and have been star
athletes if you you know someone like
Drew Brees a star quarterback he's been
in the league for I don't know 15 years
or something but that means he's really
been a star quarterback probably since
he was like 5 years old he's pretty much
his entire life he's been a star athlete
everywhere he goes to to be 8 in that
position to be able to retain some
humility and and still just be sort of
normal that is a huge feat really that
is a huge that is a huge feat of virtue
just to be able to pull that off I think
lesser people if you give if you're
given that kind of attention and you're
treated that way all the time throughout
your entire life
it's it's very difficult for it not to
go to your head so when I see athletes
like this who are just decent guys to me
I'm very impressed with that but not
everybody is impressed and the fact that
he's a decent guy that's not gonna save
him from the woke mob which have now
descended on Brees because well let me
read let me read some of the headlines
to you to give you the the woke mobs
version of what Brees has done wrong
okay let me read some headlines first
this is a headline from a website called
black sports online and I think this is
the garbage site that really kicked off
the controversy and here's how they
phrase things it was Drew Brees created
a PSA video for an anti-gay religious
cult that believes in conversion therapy
and fights against any
anti-discrimination laws wants kids to
bring Bible to school to convert other
kids okay so that's how black sports
online phrases you made a PSA video for
an anti-gay religious cult Deadspin put
it this way Drew Brees appears in video
for gay conversion therapy sickos
doesn't understand what the big deal is
and then Big Easy magazine put it this
way they said Drew Brees records video
for anti LGBT religious organization
okay so this sounds pretty bad right if
you don't know any better which you
should at this point but if you don't
know any better you hear those headlines
and you think god that's bad I mean he
he's aligned himself with a with a cult
and he's recording anti-gay PSAs well
why would he do this this is Drew Brees
we're talking about why would you even
as crazy well let's let's play the
controversial video and I want you get
ready for this because it's pretty
disturbing remember this is an anti-gay
religious called he's doing a PSA who
knows what he's about to say this is
pretty disturbing stuff so I have to
warn you if there's any kids listening
right now maybe you should cover their
ears because this is pretty dark stuff
let's listen to this hey guys drew brees
here one of my favorite verses in the
bible is 2nd corinthians 5:7 before we
live by faith not by sight
so I want to encourage you to live out
your faith on bring your Bible to school
day and share God's love with friends
you're not alone yeah so that's it
that's that's the whole thing that's the
video that created the backlash the
anti-gay religious called PSA that's
just what you saw right there that's it
he recorded that for for the group focus
on the family as a way to promote bring
your Bible to school day which is a
thing I didn't know that was a thing I'm
glad it's a thing and so on that day you
bring your Bible to school and so he did
a video saying bring your Bible school
and that's that really is it there isn't
like an additional part of the video
that I'm not showing where he advocates
the death penalty for homosexuals or
something that no that that's even
though that's what you would expect
based on the headlines that's not what
happens it's really the entire video
just him saying hey kids Bibles are cool
thumbs up and I'm drew Brees go Saints I
mean that's that's the entire thing well
in response some of the more unhinged
headlines but there were a ton of others
and all accusing him of being anti-gay
and so on and so forth and then there
was the backlash online and it was
trending and so you know the whole
rigmarole in response to the ridiculous
fake dishonest outrage breeze made
another video last night addressing it
and I when I when I solved the little
thumbnail of his video I was afraid that
he was about to apologize and I was
relieved to see that he does not
apologize here's here's what he does say
hello everyone there's been a lot of
negativity spread about me in the LGBTQ
community recently based upon a article
that someone wrote with a very negative
headline that I think led people to
believe that somehow I was aligned with
an organization that was anti LGBTQ
and and so on and so forth I'd like to
set the record straight I lived by two
very simple Christian fundamentals and
that is love the Lord with all your
heart mind and soul and love your
neighbor as yourself
no matter your race your color your
religious preference your sexual
orientation your political beliefs it
doesn't matter so the fact that these
rumors have been spread about me are
completely untrue what I did was I
filmed a video recently that was
encouraging kids to bring their Bibles
to school for national bring your Bible
to school day to bring your Bibles to
school to be able to live out your faith
with confidence and I even gave one of
my favorite Bible verses it was as
simple as that
so I'm not sure why the negativity
spread or why people tried to rope me
into certain negativity I do not support
any groups that discriminate or that
have their own agendas that are trying
to promote inequality okay so hopefully
that has set the record straight
and we can all move on because that's
not what I stand for have a great day
okay good for him for not apologizing
I'm glad he didn't drew brees is it's
kind of like we talked about Walmart
earlier in the week for Walmart caved to
the left-wing mob and there was no
reason for them to cave because it's
Walmart we're talking about the left
can't touch them they're Walmart so they
they could take a position of I don't
care what you people think we're gonna
do we want to do I mean yeah go ahead go
ahead and boycott oh oh I'm so scared
drew brees could could take a similar
approach and if I were drew brees that's
probably what I would would have done I
probably would have made a video saying
look I'm drew Brees oh you're mad at me
okay good that well that's good good for
you I'm drew Brees this is me we're
talking about folks I mean there's no
way that Drew Brees is getting fired by
the Saints especially for that video but
even if he did record an actual anti-gay
but he probably still wouldn't get fired
because he's drew Brees they'd have a
riot on their hands in New Orleans if
they did so he
he he just doesn't have to worry about
them yet he has probably too much class
I guess that's why he's drew brees and
I'm not I mean he has too much class to
get up there and say so he he tried to
explain himself a little bit
yet even breezes responds to the
original fake out outrage is
mischaracterized by the media ESPN this
is their headline talking about his
response and their headliners Brees
irate over backlash from promotional
video irate did that seem irate to you
okay that's not irate I can show you
what irate is I'm irate all the time
about everything that's that so you want
to see irate and then find but that Drew
Brees probably has never been irate
about anything that was not irate he
wasn't screaming it wasn't frothing at
the mouth he was just explaining I think
in very reasonable calm terms what
actually happened by the way this claim
that Focus on the Family supports gay
conversion therapy even if it were true
it's irrelevant because Brees didn't
mention anything about it so even if
Focus on the Family did support gay
conversion therapy whatever that's
supposed to be its it that's not what
your reasons talking about he was just
saying bring your Bibles to school and I
doubt whatever focus on the family's
position is on gay conversion therapy I
really doubt that Drew Brees knows or
cares or has he just would have no idea
I don't think gay conversion therapy is
the kind of issue that someone like Drew
Brees has really tuned into and worried
about right and I don't claim to be an
expert on focus on the family's position
on the subject either but from from what
I understand they have basically taken
the stance that if a Christian with a
homosexual orientation wants to seek
counseling from his church or from his
Christian counselor related to his
sexual orientation then he should be
able to do that from what I understand
that's focused on the family's position
I don't think Focus on the Family has
ever
said that gays should be forced into gay
conversion camps like they should all be
rounded up and brought to a camp where
they're brainwashed or I don't think
they've ever taken that position I think
their position is look if somebody wants
counselling they should be able to get
it which which to me seems perfectly
reasonable if that is their position but
anyway it's irrelevant because like I
said Brees didn't go anywhere near the
subject he just encouraged kids to bring
their Bibles to school that's all and
you can disagree with that if you want
okay yeah I mean if you want to disagree
with that that's fine but whatever
happened to just disagreeing why can't
you just say no drew brees I disagree I
don't think kids should bring their
Bibles to school here's why and then
explain personally I can't imagine what
your problem with it would be but
whatever it is just explain it no big
deal why does it have to be
automatically oh my gosh drew brees
wants to kill all gays why you have to
go there like why just if we know what
your real problem is you don't like
Christians you don't like the Bible you
don't think Bibles belong in school
that's really what you're upset about so
just say that just say it why does it
automatically have to go well I know why
you know it's a rhetorical question
and the answer is we live in very very
stupid times very stupid times and
dishonest times to where people there
are a lot of people who just seem to be
incapable of of honestly and directly
engaging with an argument or a position
I think there are a lot of people in our
country who really are in cages are
intellectually incapable of it at this
point and I have to say this as well I
know that if you're in the LGBTQ camp
you're probably not gonna take advice
for me maybe I don't I don't blame you
for that but I'm gonna give some advice
anyway okay take it or leave it you'll
probably leave it fine but
you if you're in that especially if
you're a gay activist for your left-wing
gay activist especially then I'll say
this you you really don't do yourself
any favors with this kind of stuff when
you go and attack a guy as being
anti-gay when he didn't even say
anything about gay people when you
attack someone for me as anti-gay simply
for for their religious views or for you
know promoting the Bible or whatever
then you just come off as vindictive
extremists and it turns people against
you there's no advantage for you and
it's not a smart strategy especially
because you've already won and this is
what I say to feminists to all the time
it's like you for feminists you already
won you've got all the rights in the
world you've got more rights than men
legally speaking so you've won that's it
you you one can Congrats go live your
life now all you're doing now is
undermining everything you achieve by
coming off like crazy people and finding
stupid things that complain about all
your doing you know you you you were in
a position and I'm still talking to
feminists here but we're we're almost
everyone was saying yeah okay the
feminists were right about that women
should vote women okay
everyone was agreeing and now but for
the last like 20 years now all you're
doing is making people turn against you
when there's no reason for it it's the
same thing with gay rights activists you
know if if if you're a gay person in
this country you you can do whatever you
want now you can get married you do
whatever you want you can be involved
with whoever you want you live with
whoever you want you could love whoever
you what you could do whatever you want
and in the general feeling of most
people in this country if you look at
any survey any poll I mean if you look
at anything if you just take a you know
kind of take the the general temperature
of society on this issue
most people are libertarian now on on
issues of sexuality they just don't care
what you do you knew what you want they
don't care
do what you want whatever you don't need
to tell us about it just do it that's
how most people feel which so what does
that mean it means you won you know you
won that's it you got you got what you
want
but rather than just sitting back and
saying okay we achieve that now when you
become vindictive and you go out looking
for revenge because that's it seems to
me that's what the gay rights movement
now has become it's now become well
you've already got all the rights now so
that's that's done that's over and in
fact even though the gay rights movement
the quote-unquote gay rights movement
still exists these are the same people
who will tell us that it's a settled
issue gave you know gay marriage settled
issue which we're not talking about okay
if it's a settled issue then within what
is the gay rights movement anyway well
I'll tell you what it's become it's
become a movement of vengeance now it's
about circling back around and finding
those people or at least those kinds of
people who opposed you and punishing
them and that is not only is that
morally wrong but it is just a really
stupid strategy because you're gonna
turn people against you whereas five ten
years ago most people in the country
we're saying yeah gay rights movement
good good stuff guys now there are a lot
of people who are against you now they
may not be against gay rights in and of
itself but they're against you because
of this kind of thing it's just really
stupid really stupid but hey don't take
it from me what do I know you know all
right let's
let's move on to something else reading
from a report in The Daily wire now this
is it says Wegmans Walgreens and CVS all
banned open carry in their stores on
Thursday following the same gun policy
change from Walmart and Kroger the other
day unlike the other retailers that only
called for a ban on open carry CVS
advised all customers except for
authorized law enforcement officers to
totally refrain from carrying at all at
all in their stores Wegmans posted on
Twitter is saying there's nothing more
important than the safety of our
customers employees the sight of someone
with a gun can be alarming and we don't
want anyone to feel that way at Wegmans
for this reason we prefer that customers
not openly carry firearms in our stores
I mean frankly I'm shocked that whether
this is the first time Wedman I'm
shocked that up until now you could open
carry in Wegmans of all places
Walgreens tagged anti-gun rights
activist Shannon Watts and thanked her
for her advocacy on gun control and
linked to their statement regarding open
carry policy the statement said we are
joining other retailers and asking our
customers to no longer openly carry
firearms into our stores other than
authorized law enforcement officials and
CVS also with a similar statement all
right so so we've got Walmart was first
saying don't open carry then Wegmans
Walgreens CVS Kroger all in the span of
a week I'm gonna maybe depart from the
standard conservative line on this issue
maybe because I don't really maybe I
don't know maybe my opinion on this is
actually in the majority I'm not
actually totally sure but I will say
that well remember with the Walmart
announcement I I criticized the move
back on Monday or Tuesday whenever it
was because to me it represented in
unnecessary cave to the left though in
that case Walmart had also said that
it's gonna stop selling ammunition for
semi autos and and that was the main
thing that from my perspective is worthy
of criticism I thought and I still think
that it's just an absurd political move
it's totally unnecessary to stops even
to stop selling this ammunition because
of because of
mass shooting but on the issue of open
carry in stores yes they're all making
these changes largely for political
reasons from political pressure I'm not
crazy about that but putting that to the
side for a moment putting to the side
that the catalyst of these moves just
looking at open carry itself
I don't blame stores for not wanting it
okay I don't know if that makes me a you
know that calls into questions question
my my gun rights bona fides but I I
don't play if a store says we'd prefer
if you not visibly traipse around our
stores with with a gun it just that to
me is is reasonable I don't see that as
an unreasonable request
I think in general it's perfectly
rational for a store to not want
customers to visibly bring guns into
their establishments I just I I don't
see any issue with that open carry in
general to me is pretty stupid and I can
tell you that I've lived in two
different states that had that had that
allowed open carry and in those seven or
eight years across those two states I
saw maybe five people doing it maybe
five I get off the top of my head I can
think of four or five occasions where I
actually saw someone open caring and the
reason I remember it is because it was
unusual even in a state that allows open
carry but I can remember those few
occasions where I saw someone you know
with the gun in the holster on the hip
out in the open like like a Clint
Eastwood movie or something and in all
five cases it seemed pretty apparent to
me that these folks were just showing
off that there didn't appear in the
context there didn't appear any to be
any reason at all for someone to visibly
have a gun out and so I could only
conclude that this was just a fashion
statement right they just felt cool
having it and that is look most gun
owners I'm a gun owner myself most of us
I think are are mature responsible we
care about gun safety we see
the gun as a tool right it's not a toy
but there are some people who just think
guns are cool they do treat them as toys
they like taking pictures with them and
putting the pictures online and it's
just really silly now those people
themselves aren't aren't necessarily
dangerous it doesn't mean that there are
mass killers but it does mean that
they're not the kind of mature
responsible gun owners that they ought
to be now look there may be some
legitimate reasons to open carry I can't
think of what those reasons would be
aside from professional reasons like
you're a police officer or you're in
professional security or something even
although even there if you're in
security probably it's going to be more
of a concealed carry situation but in
any case I think for the most part it's
a fashion statement responsible mature
gun owners aren't interested in flashing
their guns to people if they carry they
do it discreetly because by the way
there really is no advantage to showing
off the fact that you have a gun to
advertising the fact that head of time
you just make yourself a target if
somebody walks in ok if somebody walks
into an establishment want to do a mass
shooting and they see that you visibly
have a gun
well that means they're just gonna kill
you first before you have a chance to
respond this this this isn't like the
Wild West where you've got you know
where you've got the quick-draw you know
you can in in in point zero seconds you
can pull out the gun it no it's not
gonna be like that they're just gonna
take you down because you've advertised
the fact that you're the threat and then
they're gonna proceed to kill everybody
else if you're not advertising the gun
well then that's gonna be a different
story
in a store setting yeah there are some
customers who are uncomfortable seeing
people openly carrying guns now you
might not feel that way you might not
understand why somebody would be
uncomfortable around a gun but that's
how some people feel that's how a lot of
people feel you see it but from a
business perspective the fact that you
may be as a gun rights activist don't
understand why people feel uncomfortable
around guns or you think it's silly that
doesn't matter the fact is a lot of
people are uncomfortable with it that's
just a fact so from a business
perspective ok you've got
a large number of people who reasonably
or unreasonably are uncomfortable around
guns and then you've got a very small
handful of people who would like to
visibly bring their guns into the store
to show off so from a business effective
perspective which of those groups are
you going to be more willing to alienate
if you have to choose between those
groups if you have to choose between the
hundreds of people who aren't really
comfortable with open carry versus the
like two or three idiots who would like
to open carry in your store who are you
gonna get rid of the hundreds or the two
or three it's just it's a it's it's a
very obvious business calculation and if
we are free-market capitalist we should
be in support of that it's it makes
sense to do that also if I'm a business
owner my own comfort level with someone
open open you know with open carry is
going to be very situationally based
okay so if I'm running let's say a
mom-and-pop hardware store in Waco Texas
or somewhere in Eastern Kentucky then
yeah probably I'm not gonna be too
worried about someone bringing their
guns in it's because it's just a
cultural thing and it probably isn't
good but even although even in those
places even in Texas or in Kentucky most
people aren't open carrying even if they
can they don't but they're in that
situation probably I won't mind but if
I'm running a convenience store in
Maryland or like a gas station in Los
Angeles or or a liquor store in
Philadelphia or something yeah I'm gonna
be uncomfortable with people bringing
guns in now those states don't have open
carry but you get my point it's just
it's it's situational in general my my
own comfort level around guns not as a
business owner but just as a person my
comfort level is is all it is also going
to be situationally dependent and it
depends really entirely on who the gun
is attached to and why right so the
the gun rights people who act like they
can't understand why anyone would ever
be uncomfortable around a gun that to me
is really silly of course there are
situations where you're going to be
uncomfortable
it depends now for me if I know that the
gun owner is mature reasonable
responsible put safety first and all of
that that I'm not gonna have any problem
with the gun and in in fact a person
like that carrying a gun I'm probably
gonna be more comfortable being around
them but if I have reason to believe
that the person is immature
irresponsible flaky whatever they think
the gun is a toy you know
then then yeah I'm gonna be
uncomfortable too around the gun even as
a gun owner even has a gun rights
activist I'm gonna be uncomfortable with
that because I'm gonna think to myself
this is a very powerful and potentially
dangerous tool that it seems to me this
person is not equipped to be wielding
and the thing is it seems to me if
someone is wearing a gun as a fashion
statement
they're probably more in the latter
category doesn't mean that they're
killers it doesn't mean they're gonna
commit a mass shooting it does probably
at least mean that they're not very
mature and so yeah I'm not gonna be
crazy about being around that either
which is why even as a gun rights
supporter and a gun owner myself I don't
like open carry I think it's done I am
NOT not in favor of it one other point
here and I think that this would be
obvious but I actually found as I was
talking about this debating this issue
on social media I found some people who
really disagreed with me on this as
obvious as it seems to me that whether
or not you agree with businesses banning
open carry and these businesses they're
not even banning it they're just saying
will you please not do it will you
please we would prefer if you don't will
you respect our wishes and I've seen
I've seen there some people responding
that by saying well I don't care I'm
doing it anyway that's just stupid
you know you don't own the place it's
not your property have respects just
some just b.a.p a grown up and have some
respect for what this what they
when it's not your property but I've
also heard people say that owes this is
a rights issue and I have a right to
bring a gun wherever I want no you don't
yeah you have second Amendment rights
I've I would basically consider myself
an absolutist on second Amendment rights
just like I am on all the on all the you
know on the entire Bill of Rights in
that I think you you have those rights
but that doesn't mean that you can bring
a gun wherever you want because there's
also something else that exists and that
is very fundamental and I think even
more fundamental than gun rights and
that is property rights I am I am
definitely an absolutist on property
rights I believe in property rights 100%
and I think that is one of the most
fundamental rights we have as human
beings it's one of the things that that
sets us apart as human beings is that we
can own property and if that right is
not respected and protected and enforced
then we can't have freedom and so it's a
property rights issue if I owned the
property whether it's my business or
it's my home and I say I don't want guns
in here then you can't bring your guns
in don't bring them in it does I don't
matter you don't have to agree it
doesn't matter it makes no difference
how you feel about it this is my
property I own it I don't want it don't
bring it so as gun rights advocates we
we should just stick to that we should
be gun rights advocates we shouldn't be
worshipper we shouldn't turn them into
into idols where they become these
supernatural things and you know your
ability to carry a gun can never be
infringed in any circumstance ever no
matter what anywhere like that is not a
reasonable position that is a crazy
position and in when gun rights people
take that position it makes us all seem
like unreal
aníbal perpetually aggrieved clowns who
are always looking for a reason to
martyr ourselves and and complain we
don't want to do that so let's focus on
efforts by the government to infringe on
gun rights that's a real thing that's
happening but when a private business
says please don't bring your guns and
other customers aren't comfortable with
it it's not it's hurting our business
don't bring them in the correct response
from us is okay all right you know I
respect that and if we want to go and
shop somewhere else then we can all
right before let's say I guess we'll get
to we'll get two emails mat well show at
gmail.com Matt wall show at gmail.com is
the email address this is from Adam says
hi Matt Adam here I'm a 36 year old
bearded Rd machinist I like scotch and
love my wife and four kids as kids aged
7 to 12 I've never been soft but I've
noticed that lately I'll start crying
pretty easily when I think back to how
awesome my kids were when they were
young ages 2 to 5 and how I'll never be
able to go back and have a conversation
with them and hear the goofy things they
said and how they said them don't get me
wrong I absolutely adore my kids today
but they're becoming young adults now
and our relationships have evolved I
still pee standing up so I'm not
terribly worried that I'm becoming a
leftist I just wanted to ask if what I'm
experiencing is something you've
experienced should I be concerned about
my recent orbital leakage I appreciate
all that you do Adam I will put your
fears at rest fear not orbital leakage
among men is usually unseemly and
inappropriate but and and frankly
immoral I would even say and unethical
and should be illegal but there are
extremely limited numbers of
circumstances where it is appropriate
for a man to cry although I will
stipulate that even in those situations
in the appropriate situations it can be
okay for a man to emit up to five
dignified manly tears and and and but
but even then do it privately okay don't
be an exhibitionist keep it at five
tears and then cut yourself off and move
on with your day
but those circumstances are the end of
the movie Rudy at the funeral of a close
friend or relative after being shot in
the stomach not in a leg of the arm okay
don't be a wimp but if shot in the
stomach fine and then finally and when
thinking about your kids that that can
be that could be an acceptable time for
a man to cry about just as I said don't
go overboard with it
and I understand your feelings I you
know my kids are still in that age range
that you're reminiscing reminiscing
about and I often think to myself how
sad it's gonna be when they're older and
they've moved past this stage and that
is that it's kind of a perfect example
is we over the weekend we went to the
aquarium over the past weekend we went
to the aquarium and my kid the twins
just turned 6 our youngest is is almost
three and they absolutely love the
aquarium they were just they just
couldn't get enough but they were
running from exhibit to exhibit and Oh
daddy look at this one no this is
amazing Wow it was they were just so
excited and so much exuberance and joy
and innocence and I couldn't help but
think to myself it's gonna be really sad
because one of these days you know
they're gonna be at that age where we go
to the aquarium or something and they're
walking around hands and pockets rolling
their eyes just want to go home you know
I know that day is coming and it it
makes me sad to think about so I get how
you're feeling but then the the the
thing about being a human being is that
I know where I'm at right now as a
parent with my kids I know
intellectually that eventually I'm gonna
look back on this and be nostalgic for
it and so I do appreciate this phase but
I can't appreciate it fully because I
still get there are things about little
kids that can be very annoying of course
and taxing and draining and so I often
can be way too focused on those things
and find myself thinking aw I can't wait
till they're older we don't have to deal
with this anymore
even though I know that those things are
so small in comparison to the kinds of
problems that are probably coming down
the road as they get older and I also
know that once I'm older I'm gonna look
back on on these moments that I'm gonna
see it as just pure joy great across the
board and I'm gonna think to myself why
did you ever worry about those small
little things oh so the kid you know
woke up too early or they wind a little
bit like why did you ever carry but care
about that it's just it's such a small
stupid thing to care about it doesn't
matter how could you have ever let that
overshadow all the all of the great
things and so I know that down the line
that realization is coming yet I still
can't fully get myself out of that
mentality so it's just part of being a
human I guess this is from Maggie says
dear Matt you have a great show and both
my husband I really enjoy your views and
agree with many things you say I always
believed the moon landing I always
believed the moon landing happened until
about a year ago and would like to share
with you the reasons why I think is
unlikely that we went to the moon unlike
many deniers my belief is not based on
photos at all one although the moon
landing is widely associated with
President Kennedy all six moon landings
happen during the presidency of Nixon
from 1969 to 1972 who was a liar to
never as exploration happened without
any other country following suit how is
it that the u.s. landed on the moon more
than 15 years before you were born yet
no other country has succeeded this to
me seems very unlikely 3 how is it that
NASA has conveniently lost all the data
to make a moon landing possible again
and even after 40 plus years we have not
been able to rediscover the data anyway
for the record I'm not a crazy person I
hate thinking that the moon landing is
unlikely but unfortunately I cannot help
thinking about the politics of that time
and the deception the US government took
part of kind regards Maggie well Maggie
I appreciate the email you the the
evidence that you provided for the moon
landing being faked none of that is
evidence of anything it's not even
circumstantial evidence the fact that
President Nixon lied about some stuff as
all politicians do is not even close to
being evidence that the moon landing
didn't happen for a number of reasons
not the least of which being
for the moon-landing to be fake faked it
would require not just the president to
be a liar but lots of other people
hundred thousands of other people would
have to be in on it
not only Liars but capable of
coordinating this lie and keeping it a
secret for all of these many years
you're talking about a conspiracy on an
enormous scale not just the president
so the ethical issues of President Nixon
that to me is completely irrelevant you
say exploration hasn't happened with
other country that you cite the fact
that other countries haven't landed on
the moon as evidence that it didn't
happen no that's actually evidence that
it did happen okay because it's you're
right that this was this was during the
Cold War was during the competition
between the the Americans and the
Soviets if the Americans didn't actually
land on the moon then the Soviets would
have continued to try to get there and
eventually they would have gotten there
so that they could be the first ones to
go so the fact that after the Americans
went a few times country stopped trying
to go at least at least stop trying to
land people on the moon that's just
evidence that we actually got there and
so now other countries are saying to
themselves you know is it worth the
enormous cost and the the the danger to
human life to go land on the moon when
someone's already done it because you
know if you want to go and study the
moon then you can send Landers there and
you can you can send probes and Landers
and and several other countries have
done that including the Russians but
actually stepping foot on the moon for
the most part that was just a statement
that was just being able to say we did
it and so once it's been done it's just
it's not worth it but if it hadn't been
done then other countries would be going
and some other country by now would have
landed probably the Russians so again
the fact that they didn't that's just
more evidence that we actually did land
on the moon and then
NASA's lost all the data to make luening
moon landing possible it's just not true
it's it's it's not that they've lost the
data to make a moon landing possible
it's that they've lost number one the
funding okay we're talking about
hundreds of billions of dollars it would
require to put feet to put a put a man
on the moon again and that requires a
certain political willpower and also
public support that just doesn't exist
and hasn't existed for decades now again
the main thing that pushed us towards
landing on the moon back when we did was
the Cold War it was it wasn't it wasn't
really at least among most Americans and
certainly in the political class it was
not a desire for scientific exploration
it was a desire to beat the Soviets well
we don't really have that anymore so
there just isn't that willpower that's
why we haven't landed and also because
there isn't a specific particular reason
to put people on the moon when we can
just send a robot there and we can do
all the soil samples and everything else
that we've already done now the focus is
okay let's put a man on Mars and so I
think you know in the next 10-15 years
we're going to do that
it's just there's no reason to keep
going back and putting people on the
moon once it's been done so I think
everything you've cited none of that
amounts to evidence of anything and all
of the evidence is in favor of the moon
landing all of it is extremely in favor
of the moon landing by the way one of
the thing we planted a flag on the moon
right there is physical evidence on the
moon right now
that we were there other countries as I
said have said probes to the moon
they've orbited the moon
they've sent Landers on the moon or
rogue robots on the moon if there was no
real physical evidence that we'd ever
been there the other countries would
have discovered that by now because they
can go to the spot where we claimed we
put a flag and they can go and see oh
look there's no flag
and do what do you think they just keep
that a secret cuz I don't want to
embarrass us you think the Russians
would keep it a secret what are they
gonna say oh it's water under the bridge
let's say let's not cause any problems
for them no yeah that's the problem the
moon landing conspiracy requires not
just for almost the entire US government
to be in on it but it requires other
world governments to be in on it too
because they would know by now we never
went and yet for some reason they're not
saying it and it would be really easy
for them to prove all they'd have to say
is hey everybody the Americans say they
planted a flag at this and that
coordinate well here's a picture no flag
alright let's see here this is from
Hayden says greetings fearless and
bearded leader I am currently a senior
at the University of Alabama and I have
a full-blown case of senioritis however
I am taking a class on argumentation and
I have been chosen to build an argument
and rebuttal on the topic of athletes
getting paid
I am personally against athletes getting
paid because they're already getting
paid by getting their college paid for
I think athletes are just getting a
bunch of are just being a bunch of brats
about wanting to get paid don't get me
wrong I'm a huge fan of football but I
even think NFL players are getting paid
way more than they deserve I mean
they're just playing football not at all
contributing to our society other than
the ridiculous political stances all
that being said what is your stance on
athletes getting paid and how would you
argue for and against this subject first
of all as far as professional football
players and how much they get paid I
disagree that they're paid too much
these people are the best in the world
at what they do and when you're the best
in the world at something you're gonna
get paid a lot of money it doesn't
matter what it is okay so you could say
it's a frivolous talent playing football
but it doesn't matter if you are the
best in the world at anything you're
gonna get paid a lot you could be the
best in the world playing ping-pong you
could be the best in the world at the
yo-yo you could be the best in the world
that I don't know making pancakes I mean
if you're really the best in the world
at that thing you're gonna get paid a
lot of money for it somehow I mean it
would not be hard to to exploit that for
money so that's the first thing and and
as far as they're not really doing
anything for society I don't agree I
think the
they are they're providing entertainment
they're providing a reason you know if
you go to a football stadium you go you
enjoy it you know I'm gonna bring my son
to a football game this year and you're
with the community and it's you know you
provide a little bit of unity you
provide chances for family bonding
entertainment all that now all that
stuff that's that's not the most
important thing in the world it's not as
important as you know maybe what a what
a heart surgeon does or something but
it's still important it's something I
think that they're providing more for
society than probably a lot of us are
and in terms of college athletes getting
paid I have to disagree with you there
as well because I think college athletes
should be paid for one simple reason
because the NCAA is making billions upon
billions upon billions of dollars off of
these kids and yeah they're getting a
free college education that's worth what
you know 100 thousand bucks at most
they're worth a lot more than that to
the college and so I think for the
simple reason that they should get paid
because that's what they're worth
they're earning this money for the
schools and the schools are happy to
collect it you know you and the school
the NC double-a goes out of its way to
exploit and to capitalize on these
players so the idea that the players
can't receive any money in return to me
is crazy
the schools are merchandising they've
got video games and yeah I know that
they so you know you can't put the names
on the jerseys you can't put the name
you can't attach them it there's a day
they have things that they do to try to
pretend they're not exploiting and
capitalize but they are their expense
EAA explores every possible Avenue to
make as much money as it possibly can
off these kids and then where does that
money go it doesn't go to charity I can
tell you that that money goes to the
coaches that money goes to the
administrators that's where it goes so
does it make sense to you that there
should be at it that there should be
college coaches making tens of millions
of dollars
off of players who get paid zero it's a
simple question really there's billions
of dollars being made by college
football the money's there it's in a big
pot and it's there so question is should
all of that money go to the
administrators and the coaches who are
not actually playing in the games or
should the players get a little bit of
it because when you say the player
shouldn't get paid what you're also
saying is I think all of those billions
should go into the pockets of the
coaches and the administrators I think
they deserve what you're saying is they
deserve all of it and the kids deserve
none of it that to me I can't even I
really can't even understand that
perspective that to me is such a you
know no offense hated but it's such a
ridiculous perspective when again when
you consider the fact that the money
exists it's there it's in a giant
Scrooge McDuck vault you know imagine it
it's all there it's someone's gets going
to somebody and the idea that it should
only go to the people who don't play
just-just-just doesn't mix if the NCAA
was serious about oh this is this is
amateur this is this is about this isn't
about making money ok well then then
don't pay the coaches ten million
dollars a year don't pay the
administrators millions if you're paying
them millions then clearly it's about
money the whole amateur thing and the
amateur thing is suss it it's not
amateur when there's billions of dollars
being made that's amateur come on
no college football is basically and has
been for a long time professional it is
professional it is a it is a it is a
game that makes billions of does when
you're playing a game and earning
billions of dollars doing it even if
you're not seeing a dime of it if if
it's earning billions it's professional
by any definition of the term the fact
that it's you know that there's a that
next door to the stadium there's a
building where people are reading books
that to me doesn't mean anything that
doesn't mean that it's not professional
it is professional because of how much
money is being made I
and okay we'll just yeah I'll leave it
there yeah maybe I got 20 more minutes I
could do on the subject so maybe I'll
have to revisit it later thanks
everybody for watching thanks for
listening
have a great weekend Godspeed the Matt
Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wired production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 if you
prefer facts over feelings if you aren't
offended by the brutal truth if you can
still laugh at the nuttiness filling our
national news cycle well tune on into
the Ben Shapiro show or you'll get a
whole lot of that and much more we'll
see you there
[Music]